hallo margot ich bin ein großer fan von dir ich würde
gerne wissen was für musik du
privat hörst was ist dein
lieblingsfilm und wenn du das nächste mal in deutschland bist
freue ich mich schon
jetzt auf antworten meine lieblingsbands  sind
die Bell Brigade, die ich vor einem
Jahr entdeckt habe. Sie klingen wie ein moderner und
nehmen es mit Fleetwood Mac auf. Sie sind
Geschwister und sie sind beide großartige Sänger.
Sie haben ein Album herausgebracht, das sich jeder
anhören sollte  Song und jemand, von dem ich früher
wusste, dass dieser Song aus dem Nichts kam, ich hatte
ihn noch nie zuvor gehört, und ich denke, er,
die Tatsache, dass er ein bisschen so klingt, wie
ich finde, ist einfach sehr, sehr cool,
es stört mich nicht, ähm, ich nur
entdeckte einen Künstler namens Owen Pallet,
sein Name ist Owen Pallet, und er ist ein
großartiger Geiger, Komponist, Songwriter,
Sänger
Rtland, von dem ich nicht genug bekommen kann
Ich liebe die Coen-Brüder Ich
liebe so ziemlich jeden Film, den sie gemacht haben
, außer unerträglicher Grausamkeit und
ich denke, das ist die einzige Ausnahme Ich
komme im April zurück nach Deutschland, um zuerst auf Tour zu gehen
Tour in Norwegen als in
Nordamerika, dann gehe ich nach Schweden,
Dänemark und dann komme ich nach Deutschland,
und ich kann es kaum erwarten, so gut vorbereitet zu sein, und
ich freue mich wirklich darauf,
jetzt Konzerte zu haben, bei denen ich Songs auswählen kann
von drei verschiedenen Alben, ich denke
, es wird für ein abwechslungsreicheres Konzert sorgen,
also kann ich und ja, ich kann, ich kann
sie ein bisschen mehr mischen, als ich es auf der letzten
Tour konnte. Sam, ich freue mich darauf.
Ich bringe meine ganze Band mit und
wir machen eine ziemlich coole neue
Videoinstallation,
also hoffe ich, euch dort zu sehen